and i'm
also projecting so i hope you in the
vacuum hearing
and you want to go ahead and get out of
here
uh so my talk refactoring flex tv from
go to go
first i want just to give you a little
bit about memes you know who i am
where i'm coming from in previous life i
was a ruby developer i wrote this book
service oriented design through me and
rails i
organized the um this is going to be
really different
i have 94 slides to get through
i organize the new york city machine
learning meetup it has a lot of people
that come to it
is it really this slide oh my god uh i'm
the series editor for a book and video
series
uh for addison wesley called data
analytics
and i'm obviously the co-founder and ceo
of influx tv all right
on to the top
but first
i have a confession to make this it's
actually not a go talk
this is a talk really about api design
and software design and how
this principle optimizing for developer
happiness which is one of our
key goals at influx db uh
ultimately motivated us to do a huge
refactor of the code base and actually
all right is there is there a hookup for
this this is
no way this is going to work it
motivated us to do a refactor which was
actually
it was so big it turned out to be really
a rewriting of influx tv
uh let me just really quickly talk about
what implexity means
uh it is an open source distributed time
series database
written in go with no external
dependencies
that means once you install it there's a
single binary
and the whole thing just works you don't
have to install zookeeper you don't have
to run redis or cassandra or whatever
it's useful for metrics for time
series data obviously time series
database
uh it's useful for analytics and
it's also useful for events so this is
like a apache log file
if you look at this like when i look at
this i see discrete events but i also
see
hundreds of thousands of discrete time
series here right
200 responses over time uh hits to
explicit url
that kind of stuff um
the use cases we're designing it for are
metrics
and when people think about metrics most
of the time that's devops data
right there's sensor data and also
there's real-time analytics
so i think going over some of the
features will help illustrate
why why it might be useful to you so
first let me talk about the data model
that it uses it's a bit different than a
sql database or any of the other
nosql databases that exist well first
you do have an idea of a database like
an sql
and then you have these things called
measurements
in sql land you probably think of these
things as like tables
in our case measurements have to
something that you're measuring like cpu
load
temperature from a sensor log lines that
you're taking
clicks so some of these things are
discrete events some of them
are samples that you take at regular
intervals
then you have tags tags describe
the data that you're taking in it's
metadata and describe it right
so tags or key value pairs say region
equals us west
post equals server a building equals 23
service equals redis those are all tags
they're metadata that describe the
measurements that you're taking
then there's a concept of a series a
series
in influx db is the combination of
a measurement and a tag set now series
can actually map to
real underlying series in the database
or series can be composed on the fly
based on a bunch of other series that
you've merged together
so one series would be say
cpu load and regen equals u.s quest
that's a series now under the covers
that probably maps to
hundreds or thousands of series that
you're looking at
then within series within within this
specific series you have data points
data points have fields
which can store different kinds of
values booleans integers float64
strings or bytes so unlike
a pure regular time series database like
graphite or opentsdb
in those you essentially have your
series and you have
a single value which is a float64
with influx you can have multiple values
associated with each individual data
point
and then finally you have the timestamp
which is a nanosecond epic
all right so writing data there's an hp
api it's pretty simple you do a post did
this thing
the post that you do looks kind of like
this you have an object
you specify a database you specify
retention policy that you're writing
into
in our case 30d means we create a
retention policy where we keep the data
around for 30 days
and then you have the data points this
is an expanded
like very verbose way to write in the
data but there you can see you have a
series
a measurement name you have the tags
that describe a point
you have a timestamp and then you have
the fields
is also very simple you do again on this
url and you pass it
a query string in our case
we designed a query language that looks
kind of like sql
it's not true sql we bastardized it to
make it good for our use case
so this is what some of it looks like
i'm not going to go through every single
example i'm just going to show a couple
highlights
here we're saying select value from cpu
where host equals server right so most
equal server aid in this
case is a tag value is a field
the results that we get back we see we
have the query here
we have series and then within this we
have
a series is a collection right so in our
case we're just looking at one series
which is
cpu host equals server a here we have
columns time
value and then you have the collection
of values and they're ordered by time
here's one where we say okay do the
value
from cpu where host is either server a
or server b
so in this case we get two separate
series back one
the toast surrey one the toaster would
be
here we're taking a percentile on the
fly 90 percentile cpu
for the last four hours in ten minute
increments uh grouped by the region
so we're saying for each region that we
have give me the 90th percentile in 10
minute buckets for four hours so
we get in our case we only have servers
in us west and u.s east
so we get two series back and we get
those values
you can take multiple aggregates in a
single query
mean percentile min max
multiple different percentile levels and
there you can see you can group by
different time intervals you can go by
seconds minutes hours days
here we're doing a query to return
all the unique series within cpu so
we'll say get the
value in one hour increments one hour
buckets
for the last 48 hours group by and this
is like
a special thing here by star so that
just tells it
expand this out into every single series
that we have now
depending on how many of these you have
you may not want to do this query
and sadness because you're going to get
that same amount of data
but it's something you can do
one of the other things in the new
release that we focused on was being
able to
do discovery of data based on tag values
right the whole idea of tags is metadata
that describes these measurements and
that aids you in
discovering okay what measurements are
we taking what are the different values
we have like what services are we
running what posts do we have
that kind of stuff so some quick
examples here the query show
measurements
the result we just see oh we get names
back
right so we have cpu memory network
whatever
here we have show series so again a
series is
measurement plus asset so for each
measurement we have in the database
here we're just showing one cpu we'll
show
the columns id is always going to be
there each series has a unique id
then region and host are tags
that describe data that is in cpu so we
can see okay we have us
server a usb server
here we're saying show me all the
measurements where the service equals
reps
so we're saying okay what what
measurements are we taking for our red
services yes so you just have adjacent
with the same key
where oh yeah that is
a typo
uh so yes there you see like what the
measurements are
with tags obviously they're key value
pairs so here we're saying show me the
tag keys from cpu so we can see
what are the different tag keys we have
to describe the cpu measurements
region and host in that case or we could
say
show me the tag values
for the key equal service so this shows
us what measurements we're taking
what what services are reporting data so
here we can see oh we have redis and
apache they're both
reporting data
uh and there's a lot more underneath
underneath the
there's a lot more in in terms of
features and things that it does i
didn't want to make this exhaustive
because i wanted to get to the rewrite
stuff there are
retention policies there's automatic
down sampling and aggregation
there's clustering and some other things
all right let's talk about the rewrite
since november of just last year
we've been basically rewriting a
collectivity from scratch
um now most people when they think about
rewrite they think of this article from
2000 that joel spolsky wrote uh
and in it he says on the topic of
rewriting software from scratch
it is the single worst strategic mistake
that any software company can make
uh he was talking about um
netscape rewriting uh their whole
browser
so we know this
i read that article i read it back in
2000 i probably read it like three times
since then
and talked to a bunch of people smarter
than me that all agree
rewrites are totally insane so
if smart people are saying this why in
the hell would we do it
um this i mentioned this before
optimize for developer happiness this is
one of the things we want to do
uh now this is kind of like a
touchy-feely thing right like optimizer
uh what the hell does that mean um
in our case i think about from two
different perspectives
we have the amplified users right so
what's it mean for that
it means simple setup it means a
flexible api that lets them do a range
of things
it means an empowering api what do i
mean by an empowering api
i think of an api that empowers them to
write less code
and get more done faster they can do
things that they previously couldn't do
because inflexibility didn't exist
and it should be performant by default
when they use the api
in the default way that they're using it
it should just give them good
performance out of the box
they shouldn't have to do a bunch of
things and jump to hoops to get the
performance they want out of this piece
of software
ultimately it's something that helps
developers build
analytics applications faster that's the
thing that we're focused on
right analytics or devops analytics for
sensors
analytics or business intelligence or
user analytics whatever it is
so the other side of it is influx tv
developers
now right now that's me and
and the other people who work for influx
db and probably
about 45 people who have contributed
around the world to the code base
but hopefully that number is going to
get bigger and for them
and really this is for go programmers
right because it is a project where you
can go
we want a fast full time we want
idiomatic go code
when we started in flex db uh the three
of us were writing it initially
uh wrote a lot of gopro that is not
idiomatic
i'm probably more guilty than todd
john writing on idiomatic coco
i'm learning um but
we want that and we want it to be easy
for people to build the project
and contribute to it and
if it's going to be easy for them to
contribute to it the idiomatic code is
going to help them
but also the organization of what is
where
helps it needs to have clear entry
points so
people can say oh i want to write this
new aggregate function
so this is where i can go in the code
and it's pretty simple to do
uh and then this was the other this is
just a
snapshot github it shows 290
open issues i've had people help me
before about the number of
open issues on the project uh
i think it's a double-edged sword it
means people are paying attention
um anyway looking at those like
we want we want to figure out how to
resolve all those as quickly as possible
and looking at all those issues they're
split across what i call three different
legitimate areas of concern
the first is feature requests these
happen all the time right
people want moving average they want
different kinds of derivatives
they want ways to fill in data in
different ways uh
top and for a given period of time
exact data point for mid max there are
tons of features that people are
constantly coming to us
about
there were performance bugs so things
like
there's a high cpu load on the query
like i do a query
that pegs the cpu but actually it only
pegs one cpu
and goes supposed to be able to use
every processor so why the hell is it
only peggy more
and oh if i do a query and i say where
food equals bar
it takes me long or if i'm listing
different series in my database
it takes too long and then there are
just straight up
bugs that are in the sorcerer right uh
the number of open file handles
goes over what they've said and the
database doesn't shut down gracefully it
just kind of got absorbed
we run out of memory in the database
dies the clustering stuff doesn't work
so then the last one
so those were the three legitimate this
is the other one
for any of you who run open source
projects or contribute heavily to open
source projects
i'm sure you love this when people like
come into your github
issues and they ask a question now
for the most part i would say those are
legitimate however
they do give us some important
information
some questions that people ask point to
bad api design
they point to things and improvements
that we can make
they'll make the software easier to use
and easier to understand
so i don't think they're all diligent
so based on that we identified three
different areas of improvement
the api design structural design
problems that were limiting performance
and
underlying technology choices that were
causing bugs
that we couldn't chase down so we'll
take each one of these in turn
now api design goals it should be
understandable
it should push users in the right
direction
when they use the api as they naturally
feel they should use it
they should get expected results and
they should get expected performance
so our previous api we were pushing
people to have many many different
time series and have them encode the
metadata of the time series in the name
so this is very similar to how you do
things in graphic
right you have all this metadata there's
a long time series names and this
huge list
so another thing about
understandably beyond design was this
feature we had
well the feature now is called retention
policies which is the idea
in time series database you have data
high precision data that you keep around
for a short amount of time
you aggregate and downtime welcome that
and keep medium precision data for a
longer period of time
and then you have lower precision data
that you keep using
influx manages all of this for you
automatically and that's the goal
previously this feature was called shard
spaces how users configured it
was they would create a shard space and
they would tell the database
for any time series that matches this
regex
put it into this shardspace so that's
where these
series names come in right they say oh
if it matches this
like this then put it into the high
precision stuff
if it starts with 5m put it into the
medium precision stuff
and all this kind of counted on
the user configuring things in a certain
way
and getting it just right and the
problem was it was really
too hard to use and a lot of people
couldn't tell where their data was going
and even worse if the user added
something later if they added a new
shared space later and added a different
branch x it was possible for them to
hide data that was previously available
which is
the absolute worst thing right
so our solution here was to have the
user be explicit
at write or query template again this is
just
an api design choice which was
do we have this regex method where it's
all kind of implicit
and they can't really control it or do
we have them to be explicit
explicit turns out to be the easier
choice for
usability
so an example of pushing users in the
right direction is tax
so users wanted to do a query like this
select the mean value from cpu where
host equals server a
when they were writing in data that's
that's what they want
right and previously host people server
a was a column
so host was a column and then we have
other strings
we didn't do anything with the strings
except we could write them into the
database
so they ended up being a bunch of wasted
space so then we
thought okay well maybe we can add
indexes we can add column indexes that
allow people to index their data
the problem with that is that the user
user still has to create those indexes
if everyone is expecting strings to
behave like tags
we should just do it that way we should
just index that data and
have it so that people can query on it
and have it be fast and efficient
don't make them create indexes we
already know what they want
okay structural design problems um
so like i said we told users to have
many many different series
and how they would pull these out is
they'd say oh
this series where it matches this wrench
x or
if they're merging a bunch together they
would say select any value from merge
here where this is the example of
getting
uh the mean of the uh region
in five minute buckets uh now the
problem
with that was there was no way to make
this perform well
if they had greater than 100 000 series
and in this use case it's actually
trivial for people to have
hundreds of thousands or millions of
separate time series
and if we're matching against regex you
just have to loop through all of those
and find dimensions and there's no way
that was actually going to scale
and be performed so
our solution is to use tags and the
combination of measurement names
and tags break up the namespace of this
manager
so you're never iterating over the
entire namespace of a million series
to get back a result so another example
of a structural design problem
is the query
so in the previous version of influx
the green engine will pipe all the raw
data over the network
we run the computation and send the
summary takes back to the user
now one of the whole reasons we wrote we
wanted to write the database from
scratch
is we wanted to design a free engine
where people would get data locality
right that's the thing that we learned
from mapreduce you ship the code to
where the data lives
not the other way around
so the solution there was to completely
refactor essentially
rewrite the query engine so that it
followed a map reduced parallel
all right
underlying technology choices so here
are just some of the
some of the choices that we made that
were having an impact
on us for performance or usability or
what so
we're using protobufs to serialize the
data this is
both over the network for inter cluster
communication
and also in the database itself in the
underlying storage engine
uh this was causing a problem with
performance
basically any query that would iterate
over say a couple hundred thousand data
points
would have to marshal them all using
protobufs
and then do something so that's the
point at which you see your cpu get
packed
and the thing about the protobuf stuff
is
use of protobufs was everywhere in the
code it was
it was throughout the codebase so
our solution was to switch to rawhides
for storage so that we actually don't
have to marshal
data we don't have to serialize them on
serializing we just use raw bytes
another technology choice you made early
on was to use leveldb
as the storage engine
um there were two really big
deal breakers for us with ldb the first
was it opens too many file cameras under
the covers we actually have many
databases
open to represent different continuous
blocks of time
and that we do that so that we can evict
data efficiently
when it comes time to addiction so
there's really no way to hack around
we need to have multiple databases going
lovely on a large database we'll have
tens of thousands or potentially a
hundred thousand open files
if you have a hundred of those in a
single process
you exhaust your file handles even on a
modern system
and the other one was level dvd doesn't
support online backups to do a backup
you actually have to close the database
copy all the files and then
um and that those things
made it really really hard to transfer
shard from one server to another
so our solution was just risk of volt tv
um
i think uh
doing a full discussion of bulls is
probably outside my time range but
if people want to talk to me about how
we hold and how we
hack around writing limitations and all
that other stuff
catch me afterwards
another one was we used flecks of bison
for the parser
these were very hard to understand and
update there are some people who love
the right
jack grammers but i'm not one of those
people
um and i also have see gogo which was
kind of sucky from a build perspective
so our solution there was to switch to a
pure go parson
which is easier to understand easier for
people to come in and actually add to
and modify
and we don't have to deal with c go so
all of these things together point into
a rewrite
right we have large api changes we have
underlying technology changes
and we have code in every area getting
touched right we're removing protobox
we're pretty much touching
all of the code across the base and if
we're changing the idiomatic go code
we're pretty much touching every file in
the project right
my contention is that a refactor would
have been a rewrite
just dragged out over time
right and some of these things were
actually making underlying breaking
changes
which means people upgrading to new
versions would have to perform
painful migrations to get it done so
a refactor over time would stretch these
breaking changes out over a longer
period of time
if we just rewrite it all in one go we
can rip the band-aid off quickly
we have one migration that people can do
to get from oa
to ona and ultimately
we felt that the rewrite path
was the path that would best help us
serve this old
optimizing for developer happiness
and oh nino gives us a solid foundation
build on
and actually drive forward to 1.0 so
uh that's it
oh yeah uh we have shirts in the back
they're free
this is what the shirt looks like uh do
i have time for questions at all yeah
um are you guys like you know uh do you
have any tools
uh where like you know people have like
data in mongodb for example which is
like
time series data that they can import
into the level db what's that
like are there any tools uh like you
know with influx
db so that like you know someone can
import the mongodb data
into influx and from there oh tools to
convert data from another database into
into
um the there are people just written
like
one-off scripts we haven't written
anything specific the problem is like
there's so many different ways to
structure your database and whatever
your data and whatever database you're
coming from
it's kind of like you you have to write
a script
yeah yeah uh so two-part question uh
first is what is zone i know coming out
it
just gets i guess and uh the second is
uh are you guys addressing anything with
clustering
yes so uh the work on i know actually
originally started as a rewrite of
clustering and it was just going to be
the clustering piece
and everything else was going to remain
the same uh and then we decided
it was going to be a bunch of other
stuff
so sometime in march is the target for
on i know
we should have early testing builds out
at the end of this week maybe not until
monday
but they'll be they'll be they'll be
there so you can actually test and
test out the api and try things out
and then over the course of the next
four to six weeks we're going to be
doing
filling in a couple of apps on the
features and doing performance testing
and debunking and all that other stuff
clustering yes totally written um i'll
to talk to you afterwards about
the design of it and stuff all right in
the back
how long did the read write kick you the
clustering work
started in late august but it was just
been working on it um
and we didn't really start the full work
on rewriting
until mid-november so
from um from a project perspective the
rewrite has actually been quite painful
it's
like it's it's painful for me as a as a
creator and
one of the owners of this project to see
people asking questions on the mailing
list and logging bugs and knowing that
like
we want to fix those things but the
problem is like we just need to get
through this rewrite so
essentially it killed our velocity on
any
feature development or bug fixes since
mid-november um
but my feeling at this point is
after we get it out in march we're going
to be in a much better position
and then at that point we'll be we'll be
having incremental improvements along
the way to fix bugs and add features
um so it's basically like the pain of
four months like we're not
we're not netscape writing a
multi-million line codebase that took
multiple years
right we're we're like
eight people at this point rewriting the
code base that like two and a half
people wrote over like eight months
so yeah
yeah so i've been looking at the flights
for the past few months it sounds like a
good spot to wait until you guys are
there is a migration path from 0809 we
haven't built the migration tool
yet there is a web page
on the current doc site if you go to 08
and you go to schema design
it tells you exactly how you should
structure your schema in oa
so that you can migrate it cleanly to
the unmanned structure
all right i think about time thanks
everyone